This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If I'm being honest, I'm not a big pet guy, but I've had a couple over the years. My favorite was a snake named Chubaka that I had in grad school while I was studying corn genetics. He was pretty cool. I am definitely a pet guy. Right now, I have a dog and a cat shout out to Donnie and Lewis, but my first pet was kind of an odd one. That's producer Emmett Fitzgerald.
这里是《99%不可见》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。说实话，我其实不太喜欢养宠物，但这些年我也养过几只。我最喜欢的是我在读研究生、研究玉米遗传学时养的一条名叫丘巴卡的蛇。他挺酷的。我绝对是个宠物迷。现在，我有一只狗和一只猫——向唐尼和刘易斯致敬，但我的第一只宠物有点特别。那是制片人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。
At a party in college, my friend Will handed me this Tupperware filled with water. I took off the top and there was this little animal floating there. It looked like an adorable chubby tadpole, with legs, and this delicate feathery boa of gills wrapped around its neck. Its face was locked in a placid, almost enlightened smile, like it knew something I didn't about the secret of life. Will told me that I was holding a kind of salamander called an axoloddle, and that he was giving
在大学的一个派对上，我的朋友威尔递给我一个装满水的特百惠塑料盒。我打开盖子，里面有一只漂浮的小动物。它看起来像一只可爱胖乎乎的蝌蚪，长着腿，脖子上还围着一圈精致羽毛状的鳃。它的脸上挂着平静、近乎顿悟的微笑，仿佛它知道一些我不知道的关于生命奥秘的事。威尔告诉我，我手里拿的是一种叫做墨西哥钝口螈的蝾螈，而且他要把
this axoloddle to me. Oh yes, my favorite kind of gift, the kind you have to work really hard just to keep alive. I put the top back on the Tupperware and named her Lenny. It turned out that Will had taken about 20 axolotl embryos from a biology lab where they had been discarded. He was raising baby salamanders out of his bedroom and distributing them to friends across campus, along with detailed instructions on how to care for them. I got Lenny a big fish tank and put her right on my mantel piece.
这个墨西哥钝口螈送给我。哦，太棒了，我最喜欢的礼物，那种你得付出极大努力才能让它活下去的礼物。我把盖子盖回塑料盒上，给她起名叫伦尼。原来，威尔是从一个生物实验室里被丢弃的废弃物中拿走了大约20个墨西哥钝口螈胚胎。他在自己的卧室里抚育小蝾螈，并将它们连同如何照顾它们的详细说明一起分发给校园各地的朋友。我给伦尼买了一个大鱼缸，把它放在了我的壁炉架上。
Axeluddles are amphibians. They hatch from eggs laid in the water, but while most amphibians will eventually transform into an adult form that lives on land and walks on four legs, axeluddles are different. They never transform. They live their whole lives in the water, like teenagers that never grow up. And that's not even the coolest thing about them. It turns out that axolotls have a superpower.
墨西哥钝口螈是两栖动物。它们从产在水中的卵中孵化出来，但大多数两栖动物最终会变态成生活在陆地上、用四条腿走路的成年形态，而墨西哥钝口螈则不同。它们从不变态。它们一生都生活在水中，就像长不大的青少年一样。这甚至还不是它们最酷的地方。事实证明，墨西哥钝口螈拥有超能力。
People discovered it after observing axolotls, biting off each other's tails and legs. They realized that these animals would grow back, whatever was bit off or cut off of them. This is Jeremiah Smith, a biologist at the University of Kentucky who works with axel bottles. He says that they are nature's great regenerators. So they can regenerate their arms, they can regenerate their tail, the piece of their liver, on parts of their hearts. They can even regenerate pieces of their brain.
人们在观察墨西哥钝口螈互相咬断彼此的尾巴和腿后发现了这一点。他们意识到这些动物能够重新长出任何被咬掉或切掉的东西。这是杰里迈亚·史密斯，他是肯塔基大学的一位生物学家，专门研究墨西哥钝口螈。他说它们是大自然伟大的再生大师。所以它们可以再生手臂，可以再生尾巴，一部分肝脏，以及部分心脏。它们甚至能再生部分大脑。
As long as they're still alive, axolotls will regrow basically anything. You can't chop their head off and have them regrow their whole head, but most other things can regenerate. Those remarkable superpowers have turned the axolotl into a scientific superstar. Biologists have devoted their careers to this salamander that never grows up and can regrow
只要它们还活着，墨西哥钝口螈基本上可以再生任何东西。你不能砍掉它们的脑袋让它们重新长出整个脑袋，但其他大多数部位都可以再生。这些非凡的超能力让墨西哥钝口螈成为了科学界的巨星。生物学家们将毕生精力奉献给这种从不长大、能够再生
its toes and tail. And the dream for many of these scientists is that we might one day figure out how exactly axolotls do what they do, and maybe even learn to harness that power for humans. And this scientific obsession has turned the Axeloddle into one of the most abundant laboratory animals in biology. Today, smiling stalemanders like Lenny can be found swimming in tanks in universities all around the world, which is a little strange because in the wild, they've only ever been found in one place. Okay, well, my name is Luis Ambrano. I work in the National University of Autonomous of Mexico as a researcher in the Biology Institute.
脚趾和尾巴的蝾螈。许多这些科学家的梦想是，我们有一天能弄清楚墨西哥钝口螈究竟是如何做到这一点的，甚至可能学会为人类驾驭这种力量。这种科学痴迷使墨西哥钝口螈成为了生物学中最丰富的实验动物之一。今天，像伦尼这样面带微笑的蝾螈可以在世界各地大学的水箱里游来游去，这有点奇怪，因为在野外，它们只在唯一的一个地方被发现过。好的，嗯，我的名字是路易斯·安布拉诺。我在墨西哥国立自治大学生物研究所担任研究员。
Luis Ambrano is a biologist based in Mexico City. One of my fields is the conservation of one of the most iconic species in Mexico, which is the Asholot. There are a few different aquatic salamanders in Mexico, but Luis studies the embassistoma Mexicano, also known in Spanish as the Ajo Lotte, and in the Nahuatl language as Asholot, and in English as Axolotl, which is the most iconic of these sort of bunch of species of salamanders that lives only only Mexico City. The Axolotl has only one natural habitat and it's not some protected wilderness area.
路易斯·安布拉诺是一位常驻墨西哥城的生物学家。我的领域之一是墨西哥最具代表性的物种之一——墨西哥钝口螈的保护。墨西哥有几种不同的水生蝾螈，但路易斯研究的是墨西哥钝口螈（Ambystoma mexicanum），在西班牙语中也被称为 Ajo Lotte，在纳瓦特尔语中被称为 Asholot，在英语中被称为 Axolotl，它是生活在仅限墨西哥城的这一群蝾螈中最具代表性的一种。墨西哥钝口螈只有一个自然栖息地，而且它不是什么受保护的荒野地区。
It's one of the largest cities in the world. Axolotl City is located in a Highland Valley and hundreds of years ago, the valley was filled with five lakes. Over centuries, various indigenous groups lived around these lakes, including the Aztecs. The Aztecs farmed on top of artificial islands called Chinampus, and it was in and around these floating farms that the Axolotl thrived. The Aztecs were fascinated by these trained salamanders. They ate them, and they used them
它是世界上最大的城市之一。墨西哥钝口螈城坐落在一个高原山谷中，几百年前，这个山谷里曾有五个湖泊。几个世纪以来，各种土著群体一直在这些湖泊周围生活，包括阿兹特克人。阿兹特克人在被称为“奇南帕”的人工岛屿上耕种，墨西哥钝口螈正是在这些浮动农场内部及周边繁衍生息。阿兹特克人对这些受过训练的蝾螈着迷不已。他们吃它们，并用它们
to make medicines, and they considered the axolotl, a sacred animal. The name axolotl comes from the god Shalatl, who was a sort of shape-shifting trickster figure. According to Aztec mythology, when our son was created it was stuck in one place all the time. And so the gods decided to sacrifice themselves, to try and get the sun to move across the sky. But when his turn was up, Shaladol decided he didn't want to go through with it. He turned himself into an ear of corn and a Nagave plant. And finally, he transformed himself into ash-yeluku. These aquatic salamanders have been important symbols in Mexican culture and art. You can find them in the murals of Diego Rivera and in the poems of Octavio Paz.
来制造药物，他们认为墨西哥钝口螈是神圣的动物。名字“Axolotl”源于神明索罗特尔，他是一种会变形的骗子形象。根据阿兹特克神话，当我们的太阳被创造出来时，它一直卡在一个地方。于是众神决定自我牺牲，试图让太阳在天空中移动。但当轮到他时，索罗特尔决定他不想经历这一切。他把自己变成了一穗玉米和一株龙舌兰植物。最后，他将自己变成了ash-yeluku。这些水生蝾螈一直是墨西哥文化和艺术中的重要象征。你可以在迭戈·里维拉的壁画中以及奥克塔维奥·帕斯的诗歌中找到它们。
So it was really really attached to the Mexican culture for many many years more than 2000 years basically since we as a Mexican star here in Diwali. And for all those years, the Axelato remained confined to that valley. You basically couldn't find them anywhere else in the world. Until a French expedition to Mexico in 1863, during the trip, French officials collected a bunch of plants and animals to bring back with them to Europe, including a group of axolotls. So what we do know from historical records is that 34 animals were collected and taken to the museum in Paris. This is amphibian expert Richard Griffiths. He is a professor at the Dural Institute of Conservation and Ecology at the University of Kent. Richard says that in Paris, scientists started breeding some of those 34 salamanders that were taken from Mexico City.
所以它真的、真的很长时间以来都与墨西哥文化紧密相连，超过2000年，基本上自从我们在迪瓦利开始我们的墨西哥星。在所有这些年里，墨西哥钝口螈一直被限制在那个山谷里。你基本上在世界的其他任何地方都找不到它们。直到1863年的一次法国对墨西哥的远征，在这次旅行中，法国官员收集了一堆动植物带回欧洲，其中包括一群墨西哥钝口螈。所以我们从历史记录中得知的是，当时收集了34只动物并被带到了巴黎的博物馆。这是两栖动物专家理查德·格里菲斯。他是肯特大学杜雷尔保护与生态研究所的教授。理查德说，在巴黎，科学家们开始繁育那些从墨西哥城带回来的34只蝾螈中的一部分。
And that proved very successful, and those descendants of those animals from the Paris Museum have been spread around the world. From the very beginning, European scientists were fascinated by the axolotl's strange appearance and its perpetual tadpole life cycle. And they started using them as model organisms for laboratory research. And axolotls were suited for the job. They survived well in captivity and were easy to breed.
事实证明这非常成功，巴黎博物馆那些动物的后代已经遍布世界各地。从一开始，欧洲科学家就被墨西哥钝口螈奇异的外表和永恒的蝌蚪生命周期所迷住。他们开始将它们用作实验室研究的模型生物。墨西哥钝口螈非常适合这项工作。它们在圈养环境中存活良好且易于繁殖。
Their cells were also large and simple to study, and later on their genes proved to be easy to manipulate. This means that you can use them as a good model for carrying out laboratory experiments on things such as the development of embryos, our hormonal systems, such as the control of metamorphosis. Axolotls were important collaborators in a lot of 20th century science. They helped us understand how organs developed in vertebrates and the causes of diseases like spinal bifida. And scientists had always been interested
它们的细胞也很大，便于研究，后来事实证明它们的基因也很容易操纵。这意味着你可以将它们用作开展实验室实验的良好模型，例如胚胎发育、我们的荷尔蒙系统（如变态发育的控制）等。墨西哥钝口螈是20世纪许多科学研究的重要合作者。它们帮助我们了解了脊椎器官是如何发育的以及脊柱裂等疾病的病因。科学家们一直对
in the salamanders' regenerative talents, but it's only in the last few decades as we've come to better understand axolotl genetics that we've really started to unlock the secrets of their superpower. Their genealogy is like utterly fascinating. Jeremiah Smith has spent years of his professional life pouring over the axolotls' massive genome.
蝾螈的再生能力很感兴趣，但直到过去几十年，随着我们更好地理解墨西哥钝口螈的遗传学，我们才真正开始解开它们超能力的秘密。它们的家谱简直令人着迷。杰里迈亚·史密斯花了他职业生涯的多年时间来研究墨西哥钝口螈庞大的基因组。
In part, to try and figure out how they got so good at regeneration. Presumably, somewhere amongst all of that DNA, all of that information, is the information of how a salamander grows back a limb. One theory has to do with scarring. When humans have a large cut or some other kind of wound, the tissue that grows back is scar tissue. But axolotls don't scar. Part of what's thought to be responsible for their ability to regenerate is that they
部分原因是为了弄清楚它们是如何变得如此擅长再生的。据推测，在所有这些DNA、所有这些信息的某处，就包含了蝾螈如何再生肢体的信息。一个理论与结疤有关。当人类有了一个大的切口或其他某种伤口时，长回来的组织是疤痕组织。但墨西哥钝口螈不会结疤。人们认为负责它们再生能力的部分原因在于它们
resolve the initial wound in a way that doesn't involve scarring, or that it involves much less scarring. Jeremiah and his colleague Dr. Randall Voss recently finished building this comprehensive map of the axolotl genome. And as scientists learn more about axolotl genetics, there is a growing optimism that humans might actually one day learn how to imitate them. And so I had to ask Jeremiah the question that I imagine he's been asked dozens of times by annoying science journalists like me from your perspective, like how possible is it that humans are ever going to be able to grow back in arm? Yeah, I mean, it's a hard question to answer with any certainty. I mean, one person that interviewed me a couple of years ago, I said, you know, I mean, it's a hard question to answer with any certainty.
以一种不涉及结疤的方式，或者涉及少得多的结疤的方式来处理最初的伤口。杰里迈亚和他的同事兰德尔·沃斯博士最近完成了这张全面的墨西哥钝口螈基因组图谱的绘制。随着科学家对墨西哥钝口螈遗传学了解的加深，人们越来越乐观地认为人类有一天实际上可能会学会模仿它们。所以我不得不问杰里迈亚那个我想象他已经被像我这样的讨厌的科学记者问过几十次的问题：从你的角度来看，人类未来某天能够重新长出手臂的可能性有多大？是的，我的意思是，这是一个很难确切回答的问题。我的意思是，几年前采访过我的一个人，我说，你知道，我的意思是，这是一个很难确切回答的问题。
I mean, one person that interviewed me a couple of years ago, I said, you know, I'll be dead before I would have a chance to grow an arm back. I don't know if that's the right perspective anymore. We're probably not going to be regrowing entire arms anytime soon, but Jeremiah thinks that with the help of new genetic techniques, like CRISPR, the lessons that were learning from axolotels could help humans heal more minor wounds. I would say in the next 10 years, we might be effectively mimicking what salimanders can do.
我的意思是，几年前采访过我的一个人，我说，你知道，在我有机会长出手臂之前，我已经死翘翘了。我不知道这是否还是正确的视角。我们可能不会很快就重新长出整条手臂，但杰里迈亚认为，在像CRISPR这样的新基因技术的帮助下，我们从墨西哥钝口螈身上学到的经验可以帮助人类治愈较小的伤口。我想说，在未来10年里，我们可能在有效地模仿蝾螈所能做的事情。
I don't think that's beyond the scope of reality. Largely because of all of this regeneration research, axolotls have proliferated in research institutions all around the world. But even as we continue to breed these animals in the name of scientific progress, we are driving the wild population in Mexico to the brink of extinction. In the last 50-60 years, the population of the Asholotles become very, very low. That's Luis Zambrano again. And he says that a client really traces all the way back to the 1500s and the Spanish
我认为这并非遥不可及。很大程度上由于所有这些再生研究，墨西哥钝口螈在世界各地的研究机构中激增。但即使我们继续以科学进步的名义繁育这些动物，我们也正在将墨西哥的野生种群推向灭绝的边缘。在过去50-60年里，墨西哥钝口螈的数量变得非常非常少。这是路易斯·赞布拉诺再次发言。他说，数量锐减实际上可以追溯到1500年代以及西班牙
conquest of Mexico. In the centuries that followed, people drain the water out of the valley of Mexico and a megacity developed on top of the tri-leg bed. Today, the historic lake system is all but gone. There's really only a small marshy remnant left in the south part of Mexico City, an area known as Sochi Milco. So now we have a huge problem because we only have the 2% of the huge lake system. We only have 2% which is Sochi Milco. In this area is the only place that the has a little now can survive as a young biologist Luis wasn't all that interested in salamanders he was more of a fish guy used to be a fish man
对墨西哥的征服。在随后的几个世纪里，人们排干了墨西哥谷地的水，一个特大城市在干涸的湖床上发展起来。今天，历史上的湖泊系统几乎已经消失。墨西哥城南部实际上只留下了一小片沼泽残余，这个地区被称为霍奇米尔科。所以现在我们面临着一个巨大的问题，因为我们只剩下了巨大湖泊系统的2%。我们只剩下2%的面积，也就是霍奇米尔科。在这个地区，墨西哥钝口螈是目前唯一能够生存的地方。作为一名年轻的生物学家，路易斯对蝾螈其实并没有那么大兴趣，他更喜欢鱼，他以前是个“捕鱼人”。
I used to study and work with fish then in 1998 a colleague enlisted him to help with this big survey that they were doing of all of the axolotls in Sochi Milko. And it ended up being surprisingly difficult work. So at the beginning I didn't like it at all. So I said, okay, I will do this. I will never work with Ashilok Tuso Sochi Milko again. But then one of the most important axolotl scientists, Dr. Virginia Graue, tragically got cancer, which meant that she wasn't going
我过去常常研究鱼并与鱼打交道，然后在1998年，一位同事招募他去协助他们对霍奇米尔科所有的墨西哥钝口螈进行的大规模调查。结果证明这是一项出人意料的困难工作。所以一开始我一点也不喜欢它。所以我说，好吧，我会做这个。我再也不会在霍奇米尔科研究墨西哥钝口螈了。但随后，最重要的墨西哥钝口螈科学家之一——弗吉尼亚·格劳博士不幸患上了癌症，这意味着她将无法
to be able to finish her research. And she went to Louise to say, okay, I got cancer, but we need to finish this research. And please finish it because I won't be able to do that. And I remember that Dr. Grawe has a very, very important piece of my life now. Yeah, she gave you a mission. Yeah, she gave me a mission, actually. The second way for projects, I fall in love with the actual hotel and with Huchimiko. It was like falling in love within a second date, basically. But as he was falling in love with Mexico's much loved salamander, he was also discovering
完成她的研究。她去找路易斯说：“好吧，我得了癌症，但我们需要完成这项研究。请完成它，因为我无法做到了。”我记得格劳博士现在是我生命中非常非常重要的一部分。是的，她给了你一个任务。是的，她确实给了我一个任务。对于第二个项目，我爱上了墨西哥钝口螈和霍奇米尔科。基本上就像在第二次约会时坠入爱河一样。但正当他爱上墨西哥备受喜爱的蝾螈时，他也发现
just how much trouble it was in. In Dr. Graway's last survey of Sachi Milco in 1998, she had found that there were about 6,000 salamanders per square kilometer. But when the Wies completed his follow-up in 2003, we only found 1,000 feet square kilometer. It was a huge decline. And from the data, Louise could see that lots of juvenile axolotls weren't surviving into adulthood. And so he had to figure out why not.
了它陷入了多么大的困境。在格劳博士1998年对霍奇米尔科进行的最后一次调查中，她发现每平方公里大约有6000只蝾螈。但当路易斯在2003年完成他的后续调查时，我们每平方公里只发现了1000只。这是一个巨大的下降。从数据中，路易斯可以看出，许多幼年墨西哥钝口螈未能存活到成年。因此，他必须弄清楚为什么没有。
Why were all these baby salamanders dying? I mean, I can tell you this in less than 10 minutes, but it took us about 10 years to understand that. And science is like that. The arc of science is long, but it bends towards a truth that you can explain in 10 minutes if you're lucky. Luis and his colleagues eventually determined that there were a few different things contributing
为什么所有这些小蝾螈都在死去？我的意思是，我可以在不到10分钟内告诉你答案，但我们花了大约10年的时间才明白这一点。科学就是这样的。科学的弧线很长，但它倾向于一个真理，如果你幸运的话，你可以在10分钟内解释清楚。路易斯和他的同事们最终确定有几种不同的因素导致了
to the collapse of the population, including invasive fish species like carp and tilapia, poor water quality, and illegal development. And we saw that the population is going, it would be going to the extinction really, really fast, if we don't do anything. The combination of human obsession and human neglect has turned the axolotl into this bizarre contradiction. It's so common in universities that someone just handed me one in college. And yet, at the same time, it's an endangered species. It's a paradox that you have this species that is probably the most widespread amphibian
种群的崩溃，包括诸如鲤鱼和罗非鱼等入侵鱼类、水质恶化以及非法开发。如果我们什么都不做，我们看到种群将会迅速走向灭绝。人类的痴迷与人类的忽视相结合，将墨西哥钝口螈变成了这样一个奇异的矛盾体。它在大学里如此常见，以至于有人在大学里顺手就递给我了一只。然而，与此同时，它又是一种濒危物种。这是一个悖论：你拥有这样一个物种，它可能是世界上人工圈养下分布最广的两栖动物，
in captivity in the world, and yet it is critically endangered in the wild. That's a Richard Griffiths again. I can't think of any other species, mammal, bird, fish, reptile, and amphibian, that has a parallel with that really. Given that dynamic, you can't help but wonder if they should just release fish-reptolaran fibio that has a parallel with that really. Given that dynamic, you can't help but wonder if they should just release a bunch of the laboratory axolotels into the wild. Yeah, I thought about that too. I mean, as much as I loved Lenny,
然而它在野外却处于极度濒危状态。那是理查德·格里菲斯再次发言。我真的想不出有任何其他物种——无论是哺乳动物、鸟类、鱼类、爬行动物还是两栖动物——能与这相提并论。鉴于这种动态，你忍不住想知道它们是否应该把一群实验室的墨西哥钝口螈放归野外。是的，我也想过这个问题。我的意思是，尽管我很喜欢伦尼，
I would have happily donated her to the cause. You're a monster. Well, don't worry, it's not gonna happen because everybody that I talked to for this story said it was a pretty stupid idea. For one, the animals probably wouldn't survive anyway, and two, you run the risk of spreading diseases. But the more fundamental problem with that plan is that the wild axolotl and the laboratory
我很乐意将她捐献给这项事业。你真是个怪物。好吧，别担心，这不会发生，因为我为这个故事采访过的每个人都说这是一个相当愚蠢的主意。首先，这些动物无论如何可能都无法存活，其次，你冒着传播疾病的风险。但该计划更根本的问题在于，野生墨西哥钝口螈和实验室
axolotl, they aren't really the same animal anymore. There's a very good argument to be made to say that the laboratory animals are not axolotls. That's Jeremiah Smith again. He says that over their long history and scientific institutions, the laboratory axolotl changed. At some point, scientists introduce the albino-tiger salamander into the population. So today, the salamanders and labs are more like axolotl-tiger salamander hybrids. And they've changed in other ways too. They're a little bit like cuter and cuddlier, less like a wild creature, I guess, than like
墨西哥钝口螈，它们已经不再是同一种动物了。有一个很好的论点可以说实验室动物已经不是墨西哥钝口螈了。这是杰里迈亚·史密斯再次发言。他说，在其在科学机构的漫长历史中，实验室的墨西哥钝口螈已经发生了变化。在某个时候，科学家将白化虎纹蝾螈引入了种群中。因此今天，实验室里的蝾螈更像是墨西哥钝口螈与虎纹蝾螈的杂交种。它们在其他方面也发生了变化。它们变得更可爱、更招人喜爱，比起野生生物，我猜它们更像是
an axol from Zosha Milco. If they're cute, like, maybe you won't forget to feed them, and they'll live to make their own offspring, right? They're still great ever-generation, but at this point, the laboratory axolotl is more like a poodle than a wolf. For example, I walk into my laboratory and there's a whole bank of tanks
来自霍奇米尔科的墨西哥钝口螈。如果它们很可爱，也许你就不会忘记喂它们，它们就能活下来并繁衍自己的后代，对吧？它们依然具备强大的再生能力，但此时此地，实验室的墨西哥钝口螈更像是贵宾犬而不是狼。例如，我走进我的实验室，里面有一整排摆满墨西哥钝口螈的水箱
with axolotl's full of them. This is Dr. Randall Voss. He's a professor of biology at the University of Kentucky and the head of an axolotel research lab there. And I just walk around the facility and they just follow me, just to watch me because they know that humans feed them. They're like my dog following me around the apartment.
。这是兰德尔·沃斯博士。他是肯塔基大学的生物学教授，也是那里一个墨西哥钝口螈研究实验室的负责人。当我走过这个设施时，它们只是跟着我，看着我，因为它们知道人类会喂它们。它们就像我的狗一样在我的公寓里跟着我转悠。
No, absolutely, no, absolutely. And you have something that's really different, I think, than what we think of the axolotl from Mexico, the natural population. In my mind, it's already a different species. A species created by science and a species that probably shouldn't be released back into the wild. Like, just like we're not going to release poodles into the Yukon to hunt more.
不，完全是这样，不，完全是这样。我认为，你拥有了一种与我们想象中的来自墨西哥的自然种群的墨西哥钝口螈截然不同的东西。在我看来，它已经是另一个物种了。一个由科学创造的物种，一个可能不应该被放归野外的物种。就像我们不会把贵宾犬放归育空地区去捕猎一样。
But we have to do something, right? Don't we owe it to this animal that has given us so much? Luis Zambrano certainly thinks so. His devotion to the axolotl has only deepened over the years. It's less intense, but by far stronger. That is my feeling about the asholotus in some moments, well not in some moments, in most of the time I have them in my emotion and my heart basically that's okay. I have to do more things to save this very nice species. Luis knew that they needed to do everything they could to clean up the ecosystem at Sochi Milco, and deal with the various issues that were sending the Axeloddle to extinction. First, we have to reduce the population of Garbantilapia. Second, we have to improve the water quality,
但我们必须做点什么，对吧？难道我们不亏欠这个为我们付出这么多的动物吗？路易斯·赞布拉诺当然是这么认为的。这些年来，他对墨西哥钝口螈的执着只增不减。它没有那么强烈，但远比以前更深厚。这就是我对墨西哥钝口螈的感情，在某些时刻，好吧，不是在某些时刻，在绝大多数时间里，基本上它们都在我的情感和心中，这没关系。我必须做更多的事情来拯救这个非常美好的物种。路易斯知道他们需要竭尽全力清理霍奇米尔科的生态系统，并处理导致墨西哥钝口螈走向灭绝的各种问题。首先，我们必须减少鲤鱼和罗非鱼的数量。其次，我们必须改善水质，
and third, we have to stop the illegal organization in the Canal of Sochi Milco. But Luis also knew he didn't really have time to wait around for the government to implement some big top-down restoration program. So we decided to change the focus in terms of restoration and not to see the authorities as a solution, but the local people as the solution. In particular, they focused on the farmers or the Chinamperos, who still farm on islands in the water. Luis and his partners started working closely alongside them, and the idea
第三，我们必须制止霍奇米尔科运河中的非法违建。但路易斯也知道，他实在没有时间等待政府去实施某种宏大的自上而下的修复计划。因此，我们决定改变恢复工作的重点，不把当局视为解决方案，而是将当地人民视为解决方案。特别是，他们把重点放在了那些仍然在水中的岛屿上耕种的农民或奇南帕农民身上。路易斯和他的伙伴们开始与他们紧密合作，其想法
was to try and give farmers money and the tools that they needed to improve the habitat around their own piece of land. They designed simple low-tech filters that farmers can use to seal off individual canals. The filter helps to increase water quality and avoid the entrance of carpentelapia. They might not be able to fix sochi milko all at once, but they want to create pockets of clean, tilapia-free water, where the axolotl population can recover. It's hard to say how well these efforts are working. In his most recent surveys, Louise hasn't found a single axolotl, although he says that local farmers that he's working with have reported seeing them inside their canals. And so there's a lot at stake
是尝试给农民提供资金和他们改善自己土地周围栖息地所需的工具。他们设计了简单的低技术含量过滤器，农民可以用它们来封锁单独的运河。这些过滤器有助于提高水质并阻止鲤鱼和罗非鱼的进入。他们可能无法一下子修复霍奇米尔科，但他们希望创造出清洁、无罗非鱼的水域口袋，让墨西哥钝口螈种群能够在其中恢复。很难说这些努力的成效如何。在他最近的调查中，路易斯没有发现哪怕一只墨西哥钝口螈，尽管他说他合作的当地农民报告说在他们的运河里看到了它们。因此，路易斯的这项工作关系重大：
in Louise's work, the fate of an ancient ecosystem, and it's iconic animal. And what happens in Mexico City could also have ramifications for all those scientists studying regeneration. In addition to being a professor at Kentucky Randall Voss is the head of the university's Ambas-Stomachinetic Stock Center. They breed axolotls and distribute them around the world. We provide axolotls to people for their research efforts. In fact, they're basically THE place to go if you want axolotls to do research with. And the amazing thing about these salamanders that are being bred at Kentucky today is that their descendants of the 34 animals which were taken from Sachi Milko
一个古老生态系统的命运，及其标志性的动物。墨西哥城发生的事情也可能对所有研究再生的科学家产生影响。除了担任肯塔基大学的教授外，兰德尔·沃斯还是该大学两栖动物基因种质中心的负责人。他们繁育墨西哥钝口螈并将它们分发到世界各地。我们为人们的研究工作提供墨西哥钝口螈。事实上，如果你想要墨西哥钝口螈来做研究，他们基本上就是唯一的不二之选。今天在肯塔基州繁育的这些蝾螈神奇的地方在于，它们是150年前在
in that French expedition 150 years ago. They are the oldest population of laboratory animals in the world. Which means that Emmett's exalata-lennie probably was related to those 34 animals that were brought to Paris. Yeah, she almost certainly was. And while that lack of genetic diversity is great for doing experiments, it can also be a problem. It can lead to inbreeding. I mean, I think there are a lot of species that if you applied the same kind of management strategy over the time that axiots have been in captivity, they probably would be extinct. Randall says that there is no immediate cause for a alarm with his laboratory salamanders. But yeah, it's a concern. I mean, I do think it's important to consider that there may be other
那场法国远征中从霍奇米尔科带走的34只动物的后代。它们是世界上最古老的实验室动物种群。这意味着埃米特的墨西哥钝口螈伦尼可能与那34只被带到巴黎的动物有关。是的，她几乎可以肯定是。虽然这种遗传多样性的缺乏对于做实验来说非常棒，但它也可能是一个问题。它会导致近亲繁殖。我的意思是，我认为有很多物种，如果你在墨西哥钝口螈被圈养的这段时间里采取同样的处理策略，它们可能已经灭绝了。兰德尔说，他的实验室蝾螈并没有引起立即的恐慌。但是的，这是一个令人担忧的问题。我的意思是，我确实认为重要的是要考虑世界上可能还存在其他
sources of genetic variation out there in the world that could be used to invigorate our population. In an ideal world, they would introduce some more wild salamanders into the lab population. But those are pretty hard to come by these days. And if the wild axolotl were to go extinct at Sochi Milko, there would be no pool of genetic material left for scientists to pull from. Somewhere in the long story of the Mexican axolotl, the narrative diverged. It became two stories, one about science and biomedical innovation, and the other about habitat loss and an iconic but increasingly endangered animal. And these stories may very well continue on their separate paths, but it's also possible
遗传变异来源，可以用来为我们的种群注入活力。在一个理想的世界里，他们会将更多的野生蝾螈引入实验室种群。但如今这些很难找到。如果野生墨西哥钝口螈在霍奇米尔科灭绝，科学家将没有可供提取的遗传物质库。在墨西哥钝口螈的漫长故事中的某个地方，叙事分叉了。它变成了两个故事，一个关于科学和生物医学创新，另一个关于栖息地丧失以及一种标志性但日益濒危的动物。这两个故事很可能会继续沿着它们各自的道路前行，但也有可能
to imagine a world where they loop back together again, where Luis's conservation efforts in Mexico are successful, and a healthy population of wild axolotls is able to provide Randall's laboratory salamanders with some much-needed genetic variation. Wow, that would be the ultimate, you know, happy ending. If that, it's what you just said could happen. That would be fantastic. But Randall and the other laboratory scientists that I spoke with were really clear that the
想象这样一个世界：它们重新交汇在一起，路易斯在墨西哥的保护工作取得了成功，健康的野生墨西哥钝口螈种群能够为兰德尔的实验室蝾螈提供一些急需的遗传变异。哇，那将是终极的、你知道的快乐结局。如果刚才你所说的那种情况能够发生。那将是太棒了。但兰德尔和我都交谈过的其他实验室科学家非常明确地表示，
dream of re-growing a human arm is not the reason we should protect this endangered species. They just don't want to live in a world where magical creatures like the axolotl cease to exist. After all, it was the magic of the natural world that got them interested in science in the first place. Jeremiah Smith might spend his days in a lab now, but growing up he used to search for tiger salamanders in the fields of Wyoming. And even now, when he's not in the office, he's usually trampling around Kentucky with his kids, looking for amphibians. Not with the intent of collecting them or sampling them or doing any experiments or genetics, it's just sort of like to see them and appreciate them and then move on. Was there any, have you done it recently? Have you like seen a salamander in the wild recently?
重新长出人类手臂的梦想不是我们应该保护这个濒危物种的原因。他们只是不想生活在一个像墨西哥钝口螈这样神奇的生物不复存在的世界里。毕竟，正是大自然世界的魔力让他们最初对科学产生了兴趣。杰里迈亚·史密斯现在可能整天待在实验室里，但在他成长过程中，他曾经在怀俄明的田野里寻找虎纹蝾螈。即使现在，当他不在办公室时，他通常也会和孩子们在肯塔基州的四处践踏，寻找两栖动物。不是带着收集它们、对它们进行采样或做任何实验或遗传学研究的意图，而只是为了看到它们、欣赏它们，然后继续前行。有没有，你最近做过吗？你最近有没有在野外见过蝾螈？
Yeah, last weekend. And probably going out this weekend again to see some other ones. Even as old as I am, I still really get a check out of it. My Lenny was not a wild salamander. I didn't find her flipping over rocks in some pristine forest stream, but I got a kick out of her too. She was a sunny presence on my mantelpiece for over a year. And then without warning, she died in the night. I still don't know exactly what happened, although after talking to Randall and Jeremiah, I'm a little worried that it was probably my fault.
是的，上周末。而且可能这个周末还会出去看一些其他的。尽管我已经这么大岁数了，我仍然能从中获得很大的乐趣。我的伦尼不是一只野生蝾螈。我不是在某个原始森林溪流中翻开石头找到她的，但我也从她身上找到了乐趣。在一年多的时间里，她是我壁炉架上一个阳光般的陪伴。然后毫无预兆地，她在夜里死去了。我仍然不知道究竟发生了什么，虽然在与兰德尔和杰里迈亚交谈后，我有点担心这可能是我的错。
Like most of her kind, Lenny lived her whole life in tanks, and so we decided to give her a send off befitting a water god, a proper Viking funeral. We built a raft out of clementine crates, and later a top a pire of shredded cereal boxes. I think there were at least seven people in attendance. I said a few words, my friend will read a slightly too long Keats poem, then we lit the makeshift boat on fire and pushed her out into the Narragansett Bay. For a second it looked like the wind was going to blow the boat back to shore, and it was smolder there awkwardly against the rocks.
像她同类中的大多数一样，伦尼一生都生活在鱼缸里，所以我们决定给她一场符合水神身份的送别，一场恰当的维京式葬礼。我们用克里曼果 Clementine 柑橘箱做了一个木筏，后来又把它放在了一个由撕碎的麦片盒堆成的火葬柴堆上。我想至少有七个人出席了。我说几句话，我的朋友威尔读了一首稍微有点长的济慈的诗，然后我们点燃了那个简陋的小船，把她推到了纳拉甘西特湾。有一秒钟，风似乎要把小船吹回岸边，它尴尬地在岩石旁冒着烟。
But then it changed directions, and took Lenny out to sea. Coming up, Emmett and I are talking about the possibility of resurrecting extinct species after this. Okay, we're back with Emmett Fitzgerald. Hey, Emmett. Hello. And so you have another aspect of the story that you wanted to share? Yeah, so towards the end of my conversation with Jeremiah Smith, he brought up a kind
但接着风向变了，把伦尼带向了大海。接下来，埃米特和我将讨论在广告之后复活灭绝物种的可能性。好的，我们回到了埃米特·菲茨杰拉德的访谈。嗨，埃米特。你好。所以你还有故事的另一个方面想要分享？是的，所以在我和杰里迈亚·史密斯交谈接近尾声时，他提出了一种
of wild idea that I hadn't considered before. Basically, he told me that if the wild acts a lot, we're to go extinct in Mexico City. He thinks he could bring it back. Yeah. I mean, I guess there's this deeper question of like de-extinction, right? So are you familiar with this concept de-extinction, Roman? I mean, I think I was made most familiar with it in the movie in the book, Jurassic Park. That's basically what you're talking about, right? Yeah, that's basically the gist of it. I mean, the idea is that with modern gene editing
我以前没有考虑过的疯狂想法。基本上，他告诉我，如果野生的墨西哥钝口螈在墨西哥城灭绝了，他认为他可以把它带回来。是的。我的意思是，我猜这里有一个更深层次的问题，即去灭绝，对吧？所以你熟悉这个概念吗，去灭绝，罗曼？我的意思是，我想我在电影和书中对它最熟悉不过了，那就是《侏罗纪公园》。这基本上就是你正在谈论的，对吧？是的，这基本上就是核心。我的意思是，这个想法是，借助现代基因编辑
techniques, we could recreate something that no longer exists in the wild or something very similar. And, you know, as Jurassic Park, the idea was like to profit off of that into film theme park, but you know, when conservationists and conservation biologists are thinking about this, the idea would be that you would reintroduce that animal into the ecosystem where it quote, unquote, belongs. And so there's been, and there's, you know, real conversations are happening in the world of conservation
技术，我们可以重新创造出在野外不再存在的东西或非常相似的东西。而且，你知道，正如《侏罗纪公园》那样，这个想法是为了从电影主题公园中获利，但你知道，当保护主义者和保护生物学家在考虑这个问题时，这个想法是你会将那只动物重新引入它“名正言顺”属于的生态系统中。所以，而且你知道，保护生物学领域正在发生真实的对话
biology around this. People have talked about trying to resurrect the woolly mimith in the passenger pigeon and, you know, real conversations are happening in the world of conservation biology around this. People have talked about trying to resurrect the woolly mimith in the passenger pigeon and, you know, this relative of the zebra called the quaga. And is the notion that this is like a stunt as it was in Jurassic Park or is something actually valuable to, you know, ecology? Yeah, I mean, there's a whole debate about this.
围绕着这个。人们一直在谈论试图复活猛犸象、旅鸽，以及你知道的，这种叫做斑马近亲的斑驴。这个概念是像《侏罗纪公园》里那样只是一种噱头，还是对生态学来说真的有什么价值呢？是的，我的意思是，对此存在着一场争论。
Some people think it's like our duty to bring back species to ecology. Yeah, I mean, there's a whole debate about this. Some people think it's like our duty to bring back species that we made extinct and others think it's an extravagant waste of resources. I don't want to get into the debate, but the axolotl, you know, is sort of an interesting case study. It's not extinct yet. That's important to say, but if it were to happen, in a way, it would be a better candidate to bring back than something that's been extinct for centuries
有些人认为把我们弄灭绝的物种带回生态系统是我们的责任。是的，我的意思是，对此存在着一场争论。有些人认为把我们弄灭绝的物种带回生态系统是我们的责任，而另一些人则认为这是对资源的极度浪费。我不想卷入这场争论，但墨西哥钝口螈，你知道的，是一个有趣的案例研究。它还没有灭绝。这一点很重要，但如果真的发生了，在某种程度上，它将是一个比那些已经灭绝了几个世纪的事物更好的复活候选者，
because you have that population of laboratory axolotls. And Jeremiah thinks that if they could figure out exactly on a genetic level, like what are the differences between the lab axolotls and the wild ones, then they could basically back engineer a salamander from the lab population that was more like the wild ones and then release it into such a milk. We could probably generate an extra act of the information to sort of like make a more axolotally axolarable from the colony. What do you think about that?
因为你拥有那种实验室墨西哥钝口螈的种群。杰里迈亚认为，如果他们能在基因水平上准确弄清楚实验室墨西哥钝口螈和野生墨西哥钝口螈之间的区别是什么，那么他们基本上就可以从实验室种群中逆向设计出一只更像野生墨西哥钝口螈的蝾螈，然后将其释放到霍奇米尔科。我们或许可以生成额外的信息来从这个菌落中培育出一种更具墨西哥钝口螈特质的墨西哥钝口螈。你对此怎么看？
I mean, you would hope you would never have to do it, right? It's like, I hope my house never burns down, but if it does burn down, well, then I'll probably rebuild it. It's, you know, you wouldn't want to do it, but if you had to do it, maybe you could. Yeah, I mean, he seems like appropriately imbiblet about it. Like being cautious and not just wanting to do it
我的意思是，你会希望你永远不必这样做，对吧？这就像，我希望我的房子永远不会着火，但如果它真的着火了，好吧，那我可能会重建它。你知道，你不会想这么做，但如果你不得不这么做，也许你可以。是的，我的意思是，他对这件事表现得恰如其分地谦逊。比如保持谨慎，而不是仅仅因为你能做到就去做，显然，做事最好的方式是保护。
because you can, obviously, the best way to do things is to conserve. Yeah, exactly. But it's the choices between not having wild ax levels and having wild ax levels, then I mean, I'm for it. I think it would be a good last ditch, important thing to do for them. I mean, in a way, it would be a way for the biomedical scientists to lend their knowledge and expertise, you know, to help bring back the animal in the wild, you know, like this is a way to reciprocate all the, that the actual auto has given us.
是的，完全正确。但如果这是在没有野生墨西哥钝口螈和有野生墨西哥钝口螈之间做出选择，那么我的意思是，我支持它。我认为这将是为它们做的最后绝望但重要的事情。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这将是生物医学科学家借出他们的知识和专业知识的一种方式，你知道的，帮助将这种动物带回野外，你知道的，就像这是一种回报墨西哥钝口螈给我们的一切的方式。
Yeah, I think that's right. And you know, one of the big critiques of this sort of thing over the years has been that humans are meddling too much in nature that it feels like we're playing God. Right. That was certainly the narrative with Jurassic Park that we deserve to be eaten by Tyrannosaurus Rex if we bring Tyrannosaurus Rex in the world. Right.
是的，我认为这很对。你知道，这些年来对此类事情的主要批评之一一直是人类对大自然干涉太多，感觉我们像是在扮演上帝。没错。这当然是《侏罗纪公园》里的故事主线，如果我们把霸王龙带到世界上，我们就活该被霸王龙吃掉。没错。
That's like the role, like the Jeff Gold Bloom character is playing in the movies. Like, you know, these arrogant humans think they can mess with nature sort of thing. Yeah. The lack of humility before nature, it's being displayed here on staggers. But you know, I do think like human impacts on the natural world are so obvious and omnipresent. Now that the concern, to my mind, the concern about playing God almost feels a little bit quaint. Like we're already playing God, you know, destroying the lake system that was this animal's habitat,
这就像电影中杰夫·高布伦扮演的那个角色所起的作用。就像，你知道，这些傲慢的人类以为他们可以搞砸大自然之类的事情。没错。对大自然的缺乏谦卑，在这里得到了惊人的展现。但你知道，我确实认为人类对自然世界的影响是如此明显和无处不在。现在这种担忧，在我看来，关于扮演上帝的担忧几乎让人觉得有点古怪。就像我们已经在扮演上帝了，你知道的，摧毁了这个动物栖息地的湖泊系统，
like that's playing God. Right, if we're gonna play God, why don't we be a benevolent God? Right, right. Like at least we can try to do our best to do that. Yeah, I mean, I guess one thing that, you know, concerned that I have personally with a concept like de-extinction and the axiotals of good example here is that like in situations like this,
就像那是在扮演上帝。没错，如果我们注定要扮演上帝，为什么我们不做一个仁慈的上帝呢？对，对。至少我们可以尽最大努力做到这一点。是的，我的意思是，我想一件事，我个人对去灭绝这个概念以及墨西哥钝口螈这个好例子的担忧是，在这样的情况下，
if you know you have the possibility of bringing an animal back, you could really, I can see that people might begin to think, well, oh, well, we don't need to worry that much about that endangered animal, that axolotl or whatever endangered animal we're talking about, because we always can just use their DNA to bring them back later on. Oh, totally. It creates a moral hazard. If you know that there's this, you know, kind of safety valve to this topic, extinction
如果你知道你有把动物带回来的可能性，你真的会——我能看出人们可能会开始认为，好吧，哦，我们不需要对那种濒危动物操那么多心，无论是墨西哥钝口螈还是我们正在谈论的任何濒危动物，因为我们总是可以晚些时候利用它们的DNA把它们带回来。哦，完全会。这造成了一种道德风险。如果你知道存在着这种，你知道的，未来去灭绝的所谓安全阀，
down the line, then it could, you know, encourage us to do bad things in the present. I totally agree with you. Yeah. And you know, when I was talking to Louise, like for him, it's as much about the health of the ecosystem at Sochi Milko as it is about the axolotl on its own. You know, like he wants to save that animal because he wants to save the ecosystem that that animal is a part of. Yeah.
那么它就可能，你知道的，鼓励我们在现在做坏事。我完全同意你的看法。是的。你知道，当我与路易斯交谈时，对他而言，这既关乎霍奇米尔科生态系统的健康，也关乎墨西哥钝口螈本身。你知道的，就像他想拯救那种动物，是因为他想拯救那种动物作为其中一部分的生态系统。是的。
And the interesting thing about, you know, this is is even if you brought back the axolotl 50 years from now, it would still need a place to live. All those concerns are still relevant. You still need to have a healthy ecosystem to release that animal into. Absolutely. You create thousands of de-extincted axolotls and introduce them into the valley, and they would just die all over again. I mean, it's not like those conditions have changed that make it poorer for axolotls. Yeah.
而且关于这个有趣的地方在于，你知道，即使你从现在起50年后把墨西哥钝口螈带回来，它仍然需要一个地方生活。所有这些担忧仍然是相关的。你仍然需要有一个健康的生态系统来将那个动物放归其中。绝对的。你创造了成千上万只去灭绝的墨西哥钝口螈并将它们引入山谷，它们还是会再次死去。我的意思是，让墨西哥钝口螈处境变差的那些条件并没有改变。是的。
And to my mind, you know, like de-extinction is interesting, and I think it's like an interesting thing we should talk about, but it doesn't change the need to deal with the water quality and the invasive fish and the illegal development. If you want to have some place for a de-extincted salamander to go, you need to still work on those things. You need to make space in Mexico City for Mexico City's beloved salamander. Yeah. Yeah.
在我看来，你知道的，去灭绝很有趣，我认为这是一个我们应该讨论的有趣话题，但它并没有改变处理水质、入侵鱼类和非法开发的必要性。如果你想让去灭绝的蝾螈有个去处，你仍然需要致力于解决这些问题。你需要在墨西哥城为墨西哥城受人喜爱的蝾螈腾出空间。是的。是的。
So it's a good thing to have in our back pocket, but we have to fix everything else in addition to it. So, you know, but that's still a really fascinating science and it's, you know, an interesting thing to keep in mind as we're deciding what to do as the world changes, as the baseline shifts even more and more. Cool. Well, thank you, Emmett. Appreciate it. Thank you. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week By Emmett Fitzgerald, Mixed By Jim Briggs, Music By Our Director Of Sound, Sean Riel. Delaney Hall is the executive producer, Kirk Cole said, is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Vivian Lay, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Will Trophy.
所以把它作为备选方案是个好主意，但除此之外我们还必须解决其他所有问题。所以，你知道，但这仍然是一门非常迷人的科学，而且，你知道，当我们随着世界的变化、基准不断发生变化来决定做什么时，这也是一件值得牢记的有趣事情。太好了。好的，谢谢你，埃mett。非常感谢。本周的《99%无形》由埃mett·菲茨杰拉德制作，吉姆·布里格斯混音，音乐由我们的音响总监肖恩·里尔负责。德兰妮·霍尔是执行制片人，柯克·科尔是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括维维安·莱、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉谢马顿、索菲亚·克拉茨克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢威尔·特罗菲。
We are a part of the Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org.
我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分。现在总部设在美丽的上奥克兰潘多拉大厦以北六个街区的地方。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上 @Roman Mars，也可以 @99PI org。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接以及 99PI 的每一期过往节目。
What do you call a baby axolotl? An axolittle. Stitch our series exam. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你管墨西哥钝口螈的幼崽叫什么？一个小钝口螈。Stitcher 和 SiriusXM。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。